right now las vegas firefighters are
cleaning up this huge early morning fire
a lighting supply business went up in
flames near sahara and maryland parkway
at clogged traffic as you can see here
filled the sky with a lot of smoke
bianca holmen live at the scene right
now with the latest from investigators
bianca
you can see there is a crew still here
on scene making sure that there are no
hot spots
it was just before 4 tuesday morning
parking enforcement officers working in
the area of sahara and maryland parkway
noticed smoke three fire departments
responded to the fire of the two-story
statewide lighting center building a
lighting production and fixture company
we got inside we found a dumpster
that was on fire plus there was some
pallet shipping pallets
that was added to the fuel as crews
worked to contain the fire there was
concern that the roof could collapse
more than 60 firefighters fought the
blaze from the outside ensuring the fire
did not spread to surrounding buildings
what could be the cause
don't have any idea he says it was just
business as usual when they closed up
everything appeared to be fine
so investigators are still trying to
determine the cause of this fire that
started here at the statewide lighting
center and of course no word yet on the
cost of damages we will keep you all
updated online bianca holmen live local
now